México se ha puesto de moda en Hollywood.
Mientras Trump sigue empeñado en construir
el muro, los directores de cine mexicanos
han ganado 5 de los últimos 6 óscares al
mejor director.
Pero todo ese talento que tienen los mexicanos
para el mundo del cine desaparece cuando hablamos
de la política.
Hace un año os contábamos cómo el país
de Guillermo del Toro había dicho adiós
a décadas de bipartidismo y, sobretodo, de
corrupción.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el anterior
presidente, Enrique Peña Nieto, dejó el
cargo con los peores índices de popularidad
que ha tenido nunca un presidente Mexicano.
Y así es como empezó la presidencia de Andres
Manuel López Obrador, la nueva rockstar de
la izquierda mexicana.
Es el primer presidente que ha obtenido el
respaldo de 30 millones de votos.
Una victoria aplastante.
Y todo esto sin contar con el apoyo de ninguno
de los dos grandes partidos.
Los Mexicanos querían un cambio radical y
eso es exactamente lo que AMLO ha prometido.
Y la pregunta es… ¿Está cumpliendo?
Pues lo cierto es que sí.
Las cosas están cambiando en México… pero
parece que a peor.
De crecer más de un 2% se ha pasado a previsiones
que sitúan el crecimiento para el año 2019
en apenas 2 décimas.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik, todo apunta
a que México va a sufrir una crisis importante.
Y ya sé lo que me vais a decir: a ver, Fonseca,
este hombre no lleva ni un año gobernando
en México, ¿se le puede ya echar en cara
lo que está pasando en la economía del país?
¿Es realmente culpa suya?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
EL RENACIDO
González Iñarritu ganó su segundo Óscar
con “el renacido”.
Pero si hay un renacido de verdad en México,
ese es AMLO.
Empezó en uno de esos dos grandes partidos
mexicanos, el Partido Revolucionario Institucional
que sería el centro-izquierda.
Pero, en seguida se dio cuenta de que uno
no puede ser revolucionario e institucional
a la vez.
Así que creó su propio partido.
Un partido verdaderamente de izquierdas.
Y así es como ganó su primer gran logro:
la alcaldía de Ciudad de México.
Dirigir la capital del país supuso el trampolín
definitivo para AMLO, candidato a la presidencia
de la República en 2006.
Sin embargo, se quedó a 250.000 votos para
ganar las elecciones.
En ese momento es cuando López Obrador promovió
todo tipo de protestas.
Los suyos le aclamaron como presidente legítimo...
Pero tuvo que esperar a las elecciones de
2012 para repetir su candidatura.
Y esta vez se quedó aún más lejos de ocupar
la residencia de Los Pinos.
Cada vez se parecía más a un cadáver político
que otra cosa.
Y en ese momento, cuando nadie apostaba por
él, AMLO resurgió de sus cenizas con un
nuevo partido político: el Movimiento para
la Regeneración Nacional, más conocido como
MORENA.
Su programa podría resumirse en acabar con
todo lo que habían hecho los anteriores gobiernos
y empezar desde 0.
Con esta fórmula arrasó en las elecciones.
Y lo cierto es que no ha defraudado.
Veréis, en sistema político de México,
hay que esperar 5 meses desde que un candidato
gana las elecciones hasta que jura el cargo.
Pues bien, durante esos 5 meses, AMLO no ha
estado esperando de brazos cruzado.
En este tiempo, se ha dedicado a organizar
referéndums.
Su idea era que, nada más empezara a gobernar,
ya tendría una serie de políticas listas
para ejecutar y con el respaldo ciudadano.
Y diréis “oye, pues no es mala idea ¿Verdad?
En Suiza o Liechtenstein les encanta hacer
este tipo de cosas… ¡Y no les va nada mal!
¿Dónde está el problema con hacer referéndums?”
Pues sí, tenéis razón.
El problema es que estos referéndums no estaban
organizados por el Instituto Electoral sino
por el propio partido de AMLO.
¡Habéis oído bien!
Para que os hagáis una idea, sólo 1 de cada
5 municipios tenía urnas.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, la limpieza del
proceso electoral era… ¿Cómo decirlo?
Mejor, mirad esta noticia.
Hasta cuatro veces pudo votar una misma persona
en consulta sobre el nuevo aeropuerto
Pero aquí no termina la cosa.
Veréis, cuando hablamos de referéndums,
el modo en el que redactamos la pregunta puede
cambiar radicalmente el resultado.
En otras palabras; cambiando la pregunta puedes
conseguir la respuesta que quieras.
Por ejemplo, si yo os pregunto, así, sin
entrar en detalles ¿Queréis doblar la pensión
mensual para personas mayores?
O ¿Queréis becas para los estudiantes de
bachillerato?
¡Seguro que todos votaríais que sí!
Pues exactamente estas han sido las preguntas
de los referéndums de MORENA.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, todos estos referéndums
han tenido un 90% de síes.
Y sí, es verdad, ninguno de estos referéndums
era vinculante.
Pero a AMLO le han venido de perlas para justificar
todas sus actuaciones.
A fin de cuentas ¡Ha consultado al pueblo!
¿Y qué tipo de medidas está haciendo AMLO?
Pues aquí tenemos un ejemplo: cancelar la
construcción del nuevo Aeropuerto de Ciudad
de México.
Hablamos de un proyecto de 13.000 millones
de dólares en el que ya se habían gastado
los primeros 5.000.
Es decir, que podríamos decir que el Gobierno
de México acaba de tirar por la borda 5.000
millones de dólares.
Y diréis ¿Por qué lo ha hecho?
Pues muy fácil: convocó uno de estos referéndums
en el que votó el 1% de la población.
Y para AMLO, eso ya es razón suficiente.
Todos los políticos toman muchas decisiones
a partir de encuestas.
En el fondo, estos referéndum son una encuesta
más, sin validez jurídica.
Salvo para AMLO.
Vamos a gobernar así, preguntándole a la
gente.
Dicen que, para no equivocarse, lo mejor es
preguntar ¡Pues eso es la democracia!
¡No es la decisión de un hombre!
De dos, de tres…
De nuevo, el problema no es hacer referéndums.
De hecho, la ley mexicana contempla las consultas
populares.
Pero claro, hay que tener una autoridad independiente
y, sobretodo, es necesario que una mayoría
cualificada de gente vote.
Para uqe os hagáis una idea, hasta este año
2019, la ley decía que, para que un referendum
fuera vinculante, hacía falta un mínimo
del 40% de participación.
Pues bien, el partido de AMLO acaba de cambiar
esa ley para que ahora baste con un 25%.
Un 25% de participación son unos 20 millones
de mexicanos.
En las consultas que organizó AMLO antes
de ser investido como presidente apenas participó
1 millón.
En otras palabras, que la democracia directa
que propone AMLO es bastante discutible ¡Pero
esperad un momento porque todavía no hemos
terminado!
Os estaréis preguntando, ¿pero qué está
haciendo López Obrador aparte de organizar
consultas?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
AMLOWORLD
La presidencia de AMLO se puede resumir en
un gesto simbólico: ha decidido no trasladar
su residencia al palacio de Los Pinos.
Muchos pensaréis ¡Así me gusta!
Por fin un político que huye de los lujos,
al más puro estilo de Pepe Mújica ¿Verdad?
El problema es que… ¿Dónde creéis que
está viviendo AMLO en este momento?
Pues nada más que en el Palacio Nacional.
Es decir, que simplemente ha cambiado un palacio
por otro.
¿Para qué han quedado Los Pinos?
Pues se ha abierto al público como recinto
cultural.
De hecho, su primer gran evento fue proyectar
Roma, la película de Cuarón, y no cobrar
entrada.
Y atentos porque, en este respecto, si que
se han tomado en serio la transparencia.
Cultura deberá informar sobre cuánto se
gastó en palomitas y ponche durante la proyección
de Roma en Los Pinos
Habéis oído bien.
Que, a ver… proyectar Roma en el Palacio
de los Pinos no es malo.
Tampoco es algo bueno.
Lo que sí tiene consecuencias en la economía
y sí espanta a los inversores internacionales
son decisiones como cancelar la construcción
del aeropuerto.
México se desploma ocho posiciones en ranking
de inversión extranjera directa
México cayó a la última posición del ranking
elaborado por A.T.
Kearney
Pasa lo mismo con la reforma energética.
Tras décadas de monopolio estatal, la petrolera
mexicana Pemex se convirtió en un pozo de
corrupción.
Tenían unas deudas nachovidalianas y, de
no ser por el aval del Estado Mexicano, se
habrían ido a la ruina.
¿Qué hizo Peña Nieto?
Abrir el mercado a la inversión extranjera.
Traer a compañías de fuera de México para
subastar la explotación de campos petroleros.
El objetivo era incrementar la producción
petrolera del país y con ello generar más
riqueza.
Pues bien, el Gobierno de AMLO ya ha dicho
que en los próximos 3 años no va a hacer
ninguna subasta.
Y luego está el tema del gasolinazo.
Resulta que México le tiene que comprar el
70% de la gasolina a Estados Unidos.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque la producción de PEMEX va de
mal en peor.
¿Cuál es la solución mágica que ha planteado
AMLO?
¡Construir una nueva refinería!
Ahora bien, con Pemex sin recursos y sin inversión
extranjera.
¿De dónde saldrá el dinero?
Pues… ¡buena pregunta!
Gobierno México asumirá con Pemex construcción
nueva refinería, anuncio levanta dudas
Levanta dudas porque ninguna de las compañías
que participó en la licitación del proyecto
considera que las condiciones de la obra son
realistas.
En 2022 veremos si las empresas o el Gobierno
tenían la razón.
De lo que no hay dudas es de cómo la obsesión
de AMLO ha sido dar marcha atrás a todas
las reformas, aunque fueran positivas.
Es el caso de la reforma educativa.
México tenía un problema con los privilegios
de los sindicatos educativos.
Veréis, en casi todos los países democráticos,
los profesores de escuela pública tienen
que pasar un examen para obtener su puesto
de trabajo.
En casi todos… ¡Menos en México!
En este caso son los sindicatos quienes contratan
a los maestros.
Y el puesto de profesor es algo que se puede
vender o incluso heredar.
Una de las reformas de Peña Nieto fue intentar
implementar un sistema de educación pública
más parecido al de España o cualquier otro
país.
Y así es como surgieron las protestas más
violentas que os podáis imaginar.
Miles de docentes optaron por jubilarse antes
de tener que hacer el examen.
También que hay más de mil profesores que
fueron expulsados de las aulas tras no superar
por 3 veces la evaluación y ser reubicados
en puestos administrativos.
Pero todo esto ya es historia.
Uno de los grupos que apoyó a AMLO en las
elecciones fueron estos sindicatos de profesores.
Así que, lo primero que ha hecho López Obrador
ha sido dar marcha atrás con las reformas.
Así que, de nuevo, los profesores mexicanos
seguirán disfrutando de unos privilegios
prácticamente únicos en el mundo.
Y los niños mexicanos volverán a tener profesores
que ni siquiera han tenido que demostrar que
saben lo que enseñan.
Pero, sin duda alguna, lo más polémico de
toda su gestión ha sido la guerra contra
el narcotráfico.
Resulta que cuando la derecha gobernaba en
México, se aprobó una ley para que el ejército
pudiera luchar contra los narcos.
Claramente, esta medida sólo ha servido para
empeorar la situación.
En los últimos 12 años, México ha tenido
más de 250.000 muertes relacionados directamente
con el narcotráfico.
Y AMLO prometió en campaña que acabaría
con esta guerra.
Y diréis ¿Qué es lo que ha hecho?
Pues ahora en lugar de desplegar al Ejército
se utiliza a la nueva Guardia Nacional, integrada
totalmente por militares y liderada por un
general experto en la guerra contra el narco.
En otras palabras, ha perpetuado la presencia
militar en las calles haciendo el trabajo
de la policía.
Así son los cambiazos de AMLO: su Gobierno
ha acabado con muchos programas sociales para
reemplazarlos por otros: los creados por él
mismo.
Y algo parecido ha pasado con el aeropuerto
de México.
Todo el dinero que se ha ahorrado el Estado
al parar las obras se va a gastar en una línea
de trenes: el llamado Tren Maya.
La idea es que este tren potencie el desarrollo
del Sureste de México.
Pero… el proyecto tiene bastantes comillas.
Organizaciones mayas exigen a AMLO detener
la construcción del Tren Maya
Lo cierto es que, desde el punto de vista
económico, no está claro que este tren vaya
a generar puestos de trabajo.
A fin de cuentas, hablamos de una de las zonas
más pobres del país, donde apenas hay fábricas
que produzcan bienes para transportar.
Lo que sí parece mucho más claro es el impacto
ecológico.
Por el momento, el proyecto no tiene aprobado
ningún estudio de impacto ambiental.
Pero nada de esto detiene al Gobierno de seguir
intentándolo ¿Y de dónde saldrá el dinero?
Pues… ¡No lo sabemos!
Por el momento, los inversores extranjeros
están saliendo del país.
Y el crecimiento económico va de mal en peor.
En cualquier caso, todavía falta tiempo para
ver cómo terminará la administración de
AMLO.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
ni siquiera ha terminado su primer año.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros.
¿Creéis que el Gobierno de AMLO será capaz
de evitar una recesión en México?
¿O creéis que el dinero que está huyendo
del país no volverá?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, darle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!